THAT IS A LEGACY ON THAT ANY
PRESIDENT AFTER THREE YEARS
WOULD WANT TO CLAIM.
>> JOINING ME NOW FOR A REACTION
FROM A REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
MATT GAETZ AND ANTI-BIG SPIRITS
AND LOOKING AT THE LATEST
POLLING DATA, BERNIE SANDERS ISG
POLLING DATA, BERNIE SANDERS ISI
MOMENTUM BIG TIME.
AND HE IS, FOR EXAMPLE NECK AND
NECK AND MAY WIN IOWA, HE IS A
HEAD SUBSTANTIALLY IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE AND BOY, HIS
FUND-RAISING IS TAKING OFF WHILE
ELIZABETH WARREN IS TANKING AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THEY WILL BE
FORCED BACK TO WASHINGTON IN
JANUARY OFF OF THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL WITH A SENATE IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL.
>> PERHAPS ELIZABETH WARREN'S
DECREASES IN REVENUE AND
CORRESPONDENCE WITH THE CAMPAIGN
NOT WANTING TO PAPER WEALTH TAX.
BUT I THINK THE BERNIE SANDERS
ASCENSION IN THE POLLS IS A SIGN
THE VENEZUELA WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS SHOWING A
LITTLE LIFE HERE.
YOU JUST GOT TO WONDER, GREGG,
WHO WILL WIN THIS ON THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY?
YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN AS THE
BLUNDERING GAS MACHINE THAT HE
IS.
YOU'VE GOT KIND OF THE WEEK AND,
BERNIE SANDERS CAMPAIGN
TRUDGING ALONG BUT GAINING
MOMENTUM AND THEN
ELIZABETH WARREN WHO HAS HAD HER
EBBS AND FLOWS.
I DON'T SEE A WINNER IN THE
FIELD YET.
SPILLING YOU KNOW, CONGRESSMAN
BIGS, DEMOCRATS ARE OPENLY
WONDERING THE WISDOM OF
NANCY PELOSI, ADAM SCHIFF AND
JERRY NADLER'S IMPEACHMENT
FIRST.
THAT YOU KNOW, THE NUMBERS ARE
INDICATING THIS WILL BACKFIRE.
HAVE THEY CREATED A POLITICAL
EXPAND AND NOW THEY HAVE STEPPED
RIGHT INTO IT?
>> YEAH, THEY REALLY HAVE.
AND I THINK NANCY PELOSI'S
INSTINCTS WORK REACT -- CORRECT
A YEAR AGO WHEN BACKING UP, WE
DON'T WANT TO GET GOING ON THIS
THING.
BUT AS MATT SAID THE VENEZUELAN
SIDE OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
CONGRESS HAD LOOKED, WE HAVE TO
HAVE IT.
SHE HAD TO CUT A DEAL TO BECOME
SPEAKER BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH A
CLOSE RACE.
SHE IS TAKING THE BULL BY THE
HORNS HERE AND IT LOOKS LIKE SHE
WILL GET BORED BECAUSE OF IT.
THE REALITY IS IT'S A HUGE
MISTAKE TO THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY HAVE NOTHING, THERE ARE
PEOPLE WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESS ITSELF THAT RELAYS THEY
HAVE NOTHING AND IT'S DONE
NOTHING BUT HELP PRESIDENT TRUMP
SOLIDIFY HIS POSITION WITH
PEOPLE OF REASON THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY.
>> Gregg: CONGRESSMAN, THOSE
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND YOU
JUST REFERENCED THEM, ARE THEY
ANGRY ABOUT WHAT PELOSI AND
ADAM SCHIFF AND JERRY NADLER
HAVE DONE?
>> I THINK SOME OF THEM ARE IN
SOME OF THEM I'VE TALKED TO THEM
QUIETLY ASIDE.
THEY WANT US TO GO AWAY.
THEY WISH IT HAD NEVER HAPPENED,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, NANCY PELOSI
HAS RAISED THE MONEY FOR THEM
BUT THE REALITY IS MANY WISH
THIS THING WOULD GO AWAY.
BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO GO AWAY.
IT IS ACTUALLY GOING TO BLOW UP
IN EVEN MORE I'M AFRAID.
>> IT'S NOT JUST NANCY PELOSI
RAISES MONEY FOR THE
CAUCUS, BUT THEY USE THE MONEY
AS A POLITICAL WEAPON AGAINST
ANYONE WHO POTENTIALLY WOULDN'T
VOTE VOTE AGAINST IMPEACHMENT.
ANDY AND I OBSERVED ACTIVE
THREATS ON THE HOUSE FLOOR AT
THE DEMOCRATS TO ROLL ALONG WITH
THE RADICAL LEFT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO SUPPORT
IMPEACHMENT THEY WOULD NOT BE
SUPPORTED BY THE DNC.
>> SO THAT IS THE ACTIVE
THREATS.
THAT IS THE QUID PRO QUO.
>> WE WILL PULL THE RUG OUT FROM
YOU IN ANY WAY.
>> THE ONLY QUID PRO QUO IN THIS
PROCESS IS A QUID PRO QUO THE
DEMOCRATS DID NOT LINE UP
AGAINST NANCY PELOSI AND TO GO
OFF THE CLIFF, THEY WOULD BE
BLUDGEONED BY THEIR OWN PARTY IN
CONGRESS.
>> Gregg: IT MAY TURN OUT TO
BE THE OPPOSITE.
CONGRESSMAN BIGS, IF
NANCY PELOSI THOUGHT THE MERE
WORD IMPEACHMENT AND THE VOTE
THAT ENSUED WOULD DAMAGE THE
PRESIDENT'S POLITICALLY, THE
OPPOSITE HAS HAPPENED HERE.
I MENTIONED THE POLL NUMBERS AND
NOW THE GALLUP POLL COMES OUT,
YOU KNOW, OBAMA THE MOST ADMIRER
MAN.
TALK ABOUT A SEVERE BOOMERANG.
>> YEAH, I DON'T THINK THEY
COULD HAVE UNDERSTOOD THAT MIGHT
HAPPEN.
I THOUGHT SHE KNEW AT THE
BEGINNING, BUT LOOK, MOST
ADMIRED PERSON POLL, THERE IS A
LOT OF TAKEAWAYS THERE.
FIRST OF ALL, THERE IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO APPROVE OF THE JOB
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING AS
PRESIDENT.
BUT MOREOVER, THERE IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT ADMIRE HIM
PERSONALLY FOR TRYING TO KEEP
HIS PROMISES WHEN HE IS IN THE
SWAMP.
WHEN HE SAYS HE WOULD DRAIN THE
SWAMP, WE HAVE SEEN, AND I THINK
THE WHOLE WORLD HAS SEEN HOW
HARD THE SWAMP WILL TRY TO TAKE
IT BACK DOWN.
AND THE OTHER THING, YOU CAN SEE
HOW DIVIDED THE COUNTRY REALLY
IS.
THAT OBAMA AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
WOULD BE TIED AS THE MOST
ADMIRED MAN IN 2019 IS A
REMARKABLE STATEMENT THAT OUR
COUNTRY IS DIVIDED IN SO MANY
WAYS, BUT I THINK IT ALSO GETS
TO THE POINT YOU JUST MADE AND
THE MATCHMAKING ALONG AS WELL.
THIS IS BOOMER RINGING ON THEM
AND SOLIDIFYING AND LIFTING
LIFTING PRESIDENT TRUMP UP ALL
ALONG.
>> PART OF NANCY PELOSI HANGING
ON TO ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT
AND NOT TRANSMITTING TO PROLONGT
AND NOT TRANSMITTING TO PROLONGM
AND NOT TRANSMITTING TO PROLONGE
AND NOT TRANSMITTING TO PROLONGC
AND NOT TRANSMITTING TO PROLONGM
AND NOT TRANSMITTING TO PROLONGN
AND NOT TRANSMITTING TO PROLONGT
NOTION AS LONG AS SHE POSSIBLY
CAN, BUT IT'S NOT WORKING FOR
HER.
IT'S HAVING THE REVERSE EFFECT.
DOESN'T SHE WANT TO WALK THAT
OVER, RUN IT OVER TO THE U.S.
SENATE RIGHT NOW TO GET IT OVER
WITH?
IT IS MORE LIKE A HOT POTATO
THAN SOMETHING YOU WANT TO
HOLD ON AND HOPE IT WOULD HASH.
I DON'T ALWAYS AGREE WITH
MR. McCONNELL BUT HE MAKES A
VALID POINT, YOU DON'T GAIN MUCH
LEVERAGE AND THREATENING TO
WITHHOLD SOMETHING THAT THE
SENATE DOES NOT WANT.
AND AS ANDY POINTED OUT, YOU
HAVE A LOT OF MEMBERS AND
DISTRICT WON BY DONALD TRUMP WHO
WILL VOTE FOR IMPEACHMENT BUT
FRANKLY, WALK THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE DIGESTIVE SYSTEM
AS FAST AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE IF
YOU ARE ONE OF THOSE CANDIDATES
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL, HECK, IF
YOU ARE ONE OF THE 2020
DEMOCRATS VOTING FOR PRESIDENT,
THIS HAS NOW BECOME
ALL-CONSUMING.
THE ELECTION WOULD BE A
REFERENDUM ON IMPEACHMENT AND
RIGHT NOW, AN ELECTION WHO THE
PRESIDENT WOULD OVERWHELMINGLY
WIN IN THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
>> Gregg: BY A FAIRLY LARGE
MARGIN, CONGRESSMAN BIGGS
AGAINST REMOVING THE PRESIDENT
VIA IMPEACHMENT.
AND YOU JUST HEARD THE CLIP WE
PLAYED FROM CBS REPORTER
GARRETT, MAJOR GARRETT WHO SAID,
ANY PRESIDENT IN TERMS OF
MINORITY VOTES WOULD VOTE AND BE
HAPPY TO HAVE THIS RECORD
PLAGUING.
AND SO WHEN YOU FACTOR
INDEPENDENCE, THE MINORITY VOTE,
AND THE PRESIDENT'S RISE IN
POLLING NUMBERS PLUS HIS
TREMENDOUS INCREASE IN
FUND-RAISING, I KNOW IT'S EARLY,
BUT IS HE LOOKING FAIRLY SOLID
GOING INTO THE 2020 ELECTION?
>> WELL, WITH EVERYTHING THERE,
LIKE HIS CHANCES SIGNIFICANTLY,
BUT I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD REST
ON OUR LOYAL SPIRIT I THINK WE
NEED TO KEEP WORKING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A GREAT
CANDIDATE, AND I THINK HE WILL
WIN BIG.
I THINK SOME OF THE THINGS YOU
MENTIONED, THE RESPONSE TO FOR
INSTANCE, THE BLACK VOTE IN THE
MINORITY VOTE, BECAUSE THEY HAD
THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATES IN
THOSE DEMOGRAPHICS THAT YOU HAVE
EVER HAD.
YOU'VE HAD MORE JOBS, MORE
PEOPLE WORKING, MORE PEOPLE ABLE
TO FULFILL THEIR LIFE DREAMS.
AND WORK HARD ON THE FIRST STEP
BACK THROUGH AND A LOT OF KUDOS
FOR THAT.
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM.
THAT HAS CHANGED THE VERY NATURE
OF SOME OF THAT STUFF GOING ON.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A
SIGNIFICANT APPROVAL RATE RIGHT
NOW AMONG BLACK VOTERS.